I remember how incredibly amazingly beautiful it was that day.
It was one of the most beautiful days I've ever seen.
I was in boot camp when I found out.
I was in elementary school.
I was in Pittsburgh, Pennsylvania helping my daughter paint.
We had the television on and immediately my phone started ringing.
I went to the grocery store to buy some milk...
...and I was listening to the radio at that time and I had the news on...
...and they mentioned that a plane had crashed into the World Trade Center.
On September 11th, I will pray for the safety of the people I love.
I will remember by taking a moment to think about the three colleagues of mine...
...who did not make it out that day.
I will.
I will find a way to help someone become more literate.
I will continue to be a volunteer fireman.
I will forgive.
I will send care packages to troops overseas.
I will help somebody build a house.
I will take the kids from the Rising Stars of America Foundation to clean up the beach.
I will be praying with Jewish, Christian, and Muslim women.
I will go to a policeman or fireman, and say thank you.
I will volunteer on our local domestic violence shelter.
I will clean up my room.
I will.
I will remember by planting a tree here at the Flight 93 Memorial.
What will you do?
What will you do this September 11th?